[Music]
with every year machines surpass humans
in more and more activities we once
thought only we were capable of today's
computers can beat us in complex board
games transcribed speech in dozens of
languages and instantly identify almost
any object but the robots of tomorrow
may go further by learning to figure out
what we're feeling and why does that
matter because if machines and the
people who run them can accurately read
our emotional states they may be able to
assist us or manipulate us at
unprecedented scales but before we get
there how can something so complex as
emotion be converted into mere numbers
the only language machines understand
essentially the same way our own brains
interpret emotions by learning how to
spot them American psychologist Paul
Ekman identified certain Universal
emotions whose visual cues are
understood the same way across cultures
for example an image of a smile signals
joy to modern urban dwellers and
Aboriginal tribesman alike and according
to Ekman anger disgust fear joy sadness
and surprise are equally recognizable as
it turns out computers are rapidly
getting better at image recognition
thanks to machine learning algorithms
such as neural networks these consist of
artificial nodes that mimic our
biological neurons by forming
connections and exchanging information
to train the network sample inputs pre
classified into different categories
such as photos marked happy or sad are
fed into the system the network then
learns to classify those samples by
adjusting the relative weights assigned
to particular features the more training
data it's given the better the algorithm
becomes at correctly identifying new
images this is similar to our own brains
which learn from previous experiences to
shape how new stimuli are process
recognition algorithms aren't just
limited to facial expressions our
emotions manifest in many ways there's
body language and vocal tone changes in
heart rate complexion and skin
temperature or even word frequency and
sentence structure in our writing you
might think that training neural
networks to recognize these would be a
long and complicated task until you
realize just how much data is out there
and how quickly modern computers can
process it from social media posts
uploaded photos and videos and phone
recordings to heat sensitive security
cameras and wearables that monitor
physiological signs the big question is
not how to collect enough data but what
we're going to do with it there are
plenty of beneficial uses for
computerized emotion recognition robots
using algorithms to identify facial
expressions can help children learn or
provide lonely people with a sense of
companionship social media companies are
considering using algorithms to help
prevent suicides by flagging posts that
contain specific words or phrases and
emotion recognition software can help
treat mental disorders or even provide
people with low-cost
automated psychotherapy despite the
potential benefits the prospect of a
massive network automatically scanning
our photos communications and
physiological signs is also quite
disturbing what are the implications for
our privacy when such impersonal systems
are used by corporations to exploit our
emotions through advertising
and what becomes of our rights if
authorities think they can identify the
people likely to commit crimes before
they even make a conscious decision to
add robots currently have a long way to
go in distinguishing emotional nuances
like irony and scales of emotions just
how happy or sad someone is nonetheless
they may eventually be able to
accurately read our emotions and respond
to them whether they can empathize with
our fear of unwanted intrusion however
that's another story
[Music]
Oh
you